I need another take I'm so nervous so
nervous right now this is crazy
a baby I know I was so nervous when I
did I know I'm freaking out
um it's the hard part about this talking
about it or just like that you're
nervous you're in front of the camera
the funny part is I can talk about it
all day long with her
um it's just the camera never I've never
really been on camera you want to come
hold the camera
and then just make sure here yeah that's
good okay perfect and then yeah we're
gonna go
do you want me to ask the question yeah
okay
have you ever fallen in love and how did
you know that it was left
yes I thought that I did not or I
thought that I had fallen in love
um in past relationships but it's so
weird being in such a healthy and loving
companionship with you
um
I just I never thought that I deserved
to everything that I could give every
ounce of me that I was able to give I
didn't ever know that it would be so
wanted and desired like I've never felt
more
desired by anybody
um
you're the one
that's good
and it's crazy because you feel so much
more alone
when you feel like the world is like
you're facing the world on your own
but
[Music]
it's just peace I can hear my peace
every single decision I make has you a
part of it no matter if you're there or
not there you're always on my mind like
it's just like an extension of me
so you are just holding the camera
so how did it feel
if holding the camera as he like
it was
eye-opening it I feel like it helped me
to see myself through his eyes so for my
audience you've been in my episodes
before
in case you don't remember can you
refresh our memory on like what I asked
you that day and what your answer was I
was asked what is one of the hardest
things that I've ever been told and I
was told that I was too broken to be in
a relationship or to be loved that was
before you had met him before I met him
what a full circle moment yeah right
yeah in the same spot too we were just
on the other side of the park but you
did it yeah exactly
thank you
I loved the way he looked at me
okay there you go and I tried on 18
bathing suits and he seemed to like
everyone that I wore
but I wore it today also
I want you to know we have 117 years of
marriage together about 117 years
62 seconds and five together so we know
how to do it
I think
I think I knew it was love when it
stopped being scary and when it stopped
um
when the butterflies kind of calmed down
because I know a lot of people say that
butterflies is a signifier of love I
really disagree I think it's exciting
but I think I knew I was in love when he
made me feel
calm and safe and sometimes a little
sleepy and
yeah I think that's how I knew I just
felt comfortable and really calm and
content and it wasn't something that was
huge and explosive it was just something
that would like
I settled into
I still don't know officially sometimes
still trying to figure out fully what in
love versus love is I think for me
the most clothes I've felt to fully
being in love is just like
it's close to an obsession it's very old
school and I think in poems and I think
in songs and everything seems like
beautiful and like out of some sort of
musical literally
and I can't sleep can't eat I feel like
I want to throw up
um so like the opposite of what my
daughter said and I think it's that
where you start to lose touch with
reality sort of thing and your world
just becomes all about thinking about
another person that's the like fine line
of like is this in love or is this
you know
mental illness
it's very close that's a little darker
take but I haven't experienced this like
sleepy lovey like maybe I need to
re-assess what love means because that
was a lot
more balanced of an answer just for my
audience I'm gonna clear it up so this
was your daughter who just went and
you're noticing that your answer is like
basically the opposite basically because
she's 16 so she sounds like way more put
together than I am oh it's a good it's a
good start that's a good start in life
maybe I did a good job when I could deal
with the
the polar opposite of myself and
be at peace without the chaos
because I feel like a lot of us we like
are addicted to the chaos and
relationships and that's like the tug
and pool
that keeps us saying
so when I got married to my husband I
realized that my life was so boring now
but I was so happy
that's how I knew I was in love
you know I had this fairy tale idea of
like love uh I thought it wouldn't come
for me it's kind of a hopeless romantic
and for the longest time I thought I
wouldn't find the one I started hanging
out with my wife now it feels like my
heart's constantly
on fire like like with such passion and
since we had our daughter I just felt
even more unconditional love from both
my wife and my daughter five years ago I
wasn't doing anything with my life or I
didn't think I'd find the love and then
now here I am
[Music]
I live in a world where people hug each
other and when I met my last girlfriend
as I hug her she just fit differently
um I didn't know it was love until I
left
basically just everything she did just
like I admired like even if it was like
the smallest little thing she could just
move she just breathing made me admire
it I knew it was love when
the rest of the world didn't matter it
was just tunnel vision
I think I knew it was love the second
that I didn't care if they were a bad
person I didn't care if we had
disagreements I didn't care
if someday it would end in the moment
that's all I wanted and I did what I had
to to keep that feeling
I knew that it was love when I was
leaving and I was driving across the
country we said goodbye I was crying
so hard and it hurt
my heart hurt so badly to leave as I was
driving away
I thought to myself
I'm in love
there was lightning and the air changed
and there were Sparks and everything in
my whole world changed you remember like
the specific moment I remember
every second of that minute we touched
he caught me because I was falling and
he got me and we both went
and that was it
was it the first day or no no it was
definitely not our first date we were
not dating at all
from we were friends
we were not supposed to be dating and
then we got married
what were you not supposed to be doing
because we were both married to other
people
I'm curious what that looked like after
that moment like well there was a lot of
chaos and then it was magic
when did I realize it was love uh
to be honest it was it really wasn't a
specific thing it was it was a lot of
things I just found myself going from
liking the little things she did to
loving them
um the way she kind of
takes on baking from anywhere to cookies
to cakes especially when she bakes for
other people she puts so much effort
into it it's so cute she is like locked
in uh
the way like she just planned a trip for
us to go to Japan that was awesome and
she like took it head-on it's really her
dedication to stuff is just impressive
and she's so she's also super forgiving
of people I there's it's really hard for
me to pick out one thing I
I'm very happy when she's around uh I
get to
uh I get to be myself and I get to relax
anytime I'm over stressed I always go
and talk to her so
I don't know if that's good for you if
that's a good answer or not but it's me
kind of rambling
[Music]
that's hard I think I was so young when
I felt that I was in love with that
certain person that I felt the
connection of like it was how he treated
me like how much he texted me or how
much he would snuggle me or how much
attention he would give me that's how I
perceived love back then because like
that's what I thought was true until
that ended and
I just got told that he did not love me
for who I was that really changed my
views on love
and I think that's why I haven't
looked out for love because I don't know
what it feels like I thought I knew
but I don't so it's harsh sorry it ended
and then we got back and then we ended
and then we got back and then the last
time we tried he actually cheated on
another girl with me and we found out
and I was so heartbroken because I had
given
two years
of my life to that person
and try to change myself and try to
change a whole bunch of facades and my
looks and had an eating disorder for
that guy and did so much
when I talked about it to other people
later they were like that's not love and
I was like I thought that was love I
thought it was normal for him to make
you feel like crap a little bit I
thought it was normal for him to tell
you that he was that you're fat and
you're supposed to
lose weight
but it was normal it wasn't
if you could like imagine what you would
want it to feel like can you tell us
I have a visual input that's them them
love has a has like a definition it's
them
those are that's your best friends yeah
I'm in three videos now
hopefully I find what she has
hi everyone thank you for watching I'll
be posting bonus footage from this
episode on my patreon that means more
answers and extended cuts of each answer
if you want to see it you can sign up
I'll have it linked in my description
and if I ever do follow-ups on the
people you see in this episode that'll
be on my patreon as well thank you guys
for watching I love you all and I'll see
you next time
foreign